every time that Donald Trump mentions
chloroquine every time someone
associated with Donald Trump mentions
chloroquine reporter should start asking
do you have a personal or financial
interest in this drug becoming the
preferred treatment for coronavirus does
anyone in the Trump administration to
your knowledge have any such financial
interest now why am i mentioning this I
mentioned it first because there's
almost always some financial incentive
with this administration not just with
Trump but with people around him but I
also mention it because a major
manufacturer of chloroquine once paid
Donald Trump's former personal lawyer
Michael Cohen who's now in jail to get
access to Donald Trump remember back in
the Michael Cohen days we found out that
one of the things you could do if you
had a bunch of money and you wanted to
buy influence was you could go and you
could give money to Michael Cohen and
that would get you face time with Donald
Trump one of the largest manufacturers
of chloroquine is Novartis
Pharmaceuticals Novartis once paid
Michael Cohen a million dollars for
so-called health care policy insight
when Trump was elected in 2016 now
health care policy insight is just
political code for peddling access
because Michael Cohen knows nothing
about health care policy he was Trump's
henchmen who set up hush money payments
to Trump's mistresses Cohen of course is
now in prison but Novartis is very much
involved with Donald Trump's coronavirus
response they have now donated or at
least announced the donation always have
to be clear about that of a hundred and
thirty million doses of chloroquine to
try on coronavirus patients Trump and
everyone around him have been pushing
this drug which is one of dozens of
drugs with potential benefits when it
comes to coronavirus although
increasingly it's not clear that that's
going to pan out so that's why we have
to ask about the financial incentives
check out economists not doctor
economist Peter Navarro here saying hey
I'm a social science
test and I can tell you this stuff works
let you go to four points beginner it's
wonderful you're saying a second opinion
here what are your qualifications to
weigh in on medicines more than dr.
Anthony found you why should we listen
to you and not doctor pouchy well let me
suggest John that later in the day you
have William grace on another famous
doctor in the city of New York he has he
can talk eloquently about this but John
there's doctors disagree about things
all the time my qualifications in terms
of looking at the science is that I'm a
social scientist a PhD and I understand
how to read statistical studies whether
it's in medicine the law economics or
whatever I'm sorry that doesn't qualify
you to treat me you know hang on John
John John John John
now this is an entire other discussion
but social science is not science in the
way that medicine is science there's a
big debate to be had about social
science as a science versus a humanity
that's not the discussion today social
science is not medical science and the
point is everyone seems desperate to
claim that they know chloroquine works
to treat coronavirus so of course is
this proof that there's a financial
incentive for Trump to promote this one
possible treatment over others no this
isn't proof but it is yet again another
instance of a financial entanglement
surfacing after just a little bit of
Investigation Novartis having previously
paid Michael Cohen for access to Donald
Trump everything's for sale
the my pillow guy makes some masks and
loves Trump and he gets to speak at a
coronavirus press briefing Gordon
Sunland bought himself an ambassadorship
not actually rare in politics in general
I would love to know who else might have
made financial moves around chloroquine
whether it's Rudy or you know dr. oz
Trump's kids or whoever now because it's
going to become a story I want to say a
little bit more about this it has been
revealed that Donald Trump has a sort of
indirect financial
connection to one company that makes
chloroquine the New York Times reports
that as of last year
Trump reported that is three family
trusts each had investments in a Dodge
and Cox mutual fund whose largest
holding was in Sanofi which is another
manufacturer of chloroquine I actually
don't think that's the real story for a
guy as rich as Trump this is this is not
really a huge thing you know I think the
chloroquine thing is not so much Trump's
personal financial financial interest
which is through a mutual fund in a
trust its companies are paying for
access many of trumps donors and allies
have ties this is a little too small in
my mind to be these story but we will
see what turns up and we should all be
asking what is the financial connection
here because it seems pretty clear that
on a number of different fronts there
appears to be one Thursday 2:00 p.m.
Eastern David Pakman show membership
explosion we lost 389 members in March
because people are struggling because of
the virus we get it so what we're doing
is this Thursday an email is going to go
out to all of our newsletter subscribers
with a one-time use coupon code or a
massive membership discount on our
website the reason is we want to try to
pull back some of those large numbers of
members that we lost so sign up for my
newsletter at david pakman.com Thursday
2:00 p.m. Eastern 11:00 a.m. Pacific
you'll be notified about this massive
membership special I invite you in in
the meantime keep me posted how's your
quarantine going I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman privacy calm is one of our
sponsors and they're giving you $5.00
just for using their free service at
privacy comm slash Pakman privacy's of
service I've been using for a while now
I love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free and it's
very quick to set up and here's how it
works when you pay for something online
or over the phone instead of exposing
your real credit card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers the payments are withdrawn from
your checking account
but your real card number stays
completely private and you do it all
with one click you can autofill the card
number in your web browser on the phone
you can create 12 virtual cards a month
you can set spending limits freeze them
delete them whenever you want I
especially love it for free trials where
you need to give a credit card number
because I can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as I give it to the
company and I know I won't be charged in
the future if you're ordering food over
the phone why do I need to give a
restaurant my real card number I don't
have to companies don't have to know who
you are your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free they
do have a paid version with different
tiers where you can create more virtual
credit card numbers per month cash back
rewards extra security features but go
ahead and sign up for the free service
it's a no brainer companies can't charge
you unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman